[Musique]
donc moi pour le moment je n'avais pas
prévu de décider des suites
bonne nouvelle je peux de nouveau fermé
le bouton morzine mauvaise nouvelle je
ne suis pas dedans
may cry est ce que tu peux faire s'il te
plaît apparaître
un mouchoir attention le mouchoir de
mcfly attention
mesdemoiselles et messieurs sur le plus
grand chapiteau et de sport
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à johann pitout l'oppidum
orange uk news sans moi sauvage game of
death metal most of my world et my
madame je suis pas là l'infirmerie s'il
vous plaît j'ai mal au tibia merci
madame je peux l'être infirmerie supplée
j'ai des moments là
regardez regardez regardez
joker
ici
[Musique]